comienza la carrera de ahorro de gas del
7 establecido para españa' después del
acuerdo alcanzado con la unión europea
para
disminuir los efectos de la guerra en
ucrania en el país hoy miércoles 10 de
agosto entran en vigor algunas de las
restricciones impuestas por el gobierno
de pedro sánchez entre ellas el uso del
aire acondicionado y de la calefacción
el aire acondicionado durante los meses
de verano no podrá estar por debajo de
los 27 grados celsius aunque hay algunas
excepciones como por ejemplo en
restaurantes o en lugares como mercados
de comida donde la seguridad alimentaria
tiene que mantener una temperatura
definida y en los meses de invierno la
calefacción no podrá estar por encima de
los 19 grados además de estas
restricciones hoy también entra en vigor
el cierre el apagado perdón de los del
alumbrado en edificios públicos y de los
escaparates que a partir de las 10 de la
noche tendrán que estar apagados siempre
y cuando no quede gente en su interior
estas medidas estarán en vigor hasta
noviembre del año que viene de 2000 el
30 de septiembre además entran otras
medidas en vigor como por ejemplo el
cierre de puertas en establecimientos
que no podrán dejar que la energía se
desperdicie tanto el aire acondicionado
como la calefacción por tener como por
ejemplo este establecimiento las puertas
abiertas tendrán que tener un sistema
aunque sea rudimentario para evitar el
despilfarro de energía aunque provenga
de fuentes renovables todo esto con
todas estas medidas de restricción el
gobierno de pedro sánchez pretende
reducir su consumo de gas entre un 4 y
un 5 por ciento